a decade ago this tiny Fox was on the
brink of extinction got a mama here kiss
your teeth now the island Fox is back
and it's coming off the endangered
species list mama you want to go is an
exceptional success to be able to take a
species off the endangered species list
particularly the Fox it's the fastest
mammal recovery in the history of the
Endangered Species Act for years
scientists like Christina bozer have
been working to restore the ecological
balance to the Foxes home santa cruz and
the other channel islands off the coast
of southern california santa cruz island
is a very special place it's the most
biodiverse
island in the california island has a
great history of human use as well as a
number of really special species humans
have used the island for ranching
military operations and recreation
bringing new species into a fragile
ecosystem scientists are now doing
everything they can to protect and
restore the islands ecological balance
by waging war against the invaders from
destructive ants to feral pigs these
were pigs that had been brought over by
ranchers around 1850 or so and they
attracted Golden Eagles which were a
non-native predator and this Golden
Eagle population grew to the point that
it was taking not just pigs but also
continuing baby foxes unable to cope
with the Golden Eagles the population
crashed to fewer than 100 foxes it's
pretty clear what we had to do to try to
save the island Fox get rid of the feral
pigs all of them that task fell on a new
zealand-based crew of hunters which
killed over 5,000 swine conservationists
captured the Golden Eagles and sent them
back to the mainland the remaining foxes
went into a captive breeding program
amazingly it worked
the Fox population soared decade later
from that last Golden Eagle capture
we're seeing over 2000 foxes on Santa
Cruz Island now scientists are trying to
restore ecological balance to other
parts of the island taking on the
invasive Argentine ant Argentine ants
remove pollen from flowers they also
kill other native ants and generally can
affect the ecology of the place from the
bottom up so bows are concocted a way to
control them from the top down this
helicopter drops what bozer calls sugar
balls of death onto argentine ant
populations across the islands rugged
terrain we wanted to do an eradication
and that had never been done on an area
of this size or scale or scope Argentine
ants will stop eating if they detect a
toxin but because the balls contain so
little poison the ants don't know what
hit them you haven't been able to find
any Argentine ants and months that's
pretty exciting we're also starting to
see native ants return to these
locations pest controllers are now using
bozer's Argentine ant control method
around the world ants maybe aren't as
cute as foxes but I think we can also
contribute to conservation by studying
some of the maybe less charismatic
animals like the ants and bows or says
conservationists can apply the lessons
of the Fox recovery and ant eradication
to other imperiled species so we as a
society made a decision to protect the
island Fox there's a very good condition
and I think in the future climate change
is gonna throw them a few other species
that we care about that protection will
require constant vigilance to safeguard
the island from invading species you're
obligated to keep a pulse on the
population for at least five years after
the foxes are delisted this means that
we'll continue to figure out how many
foxes are out in the wild we'll also
keep track on their survival rate and
we'll also make sure that we're
vaccinating these foxes because
currently the biggest threat to this
population is introduced diseases from
the mainland you know girl yeah you want
to get going